The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Welcome back.
Over the last
couple of lectures,
we've been looking at
optimization models.
And the idea was how do I find
a way to optimize an objective
function-- it could be
minimize it or maximize it--
relative to a set
of constraints?
And we saw, or
Professor Guttag showed
you, one of the ways
that naturally falls out
is by looking at
trees, decision trees,
where you pass your way through
a tree trying to figure out
how to optimize that model.
So today, we're going to
generalize those trees
into another whole broad
class of models called graph
theoretic or graph models.
And we're going to use
those to again look
at how do we can do optimization
on those kinds of models.
Just to remind you,
there is a great piece
of information in the text.
There's the reading for today.
And these will, of
course, be in the slides
that you can download.
So let's take a second
just to reset again
what are we trying to do?
Generally, we're trying to
build computational models.
So what does that mean?
The same way we could do
a physical experiment,
or a social experiment,
or model, if you like,
a physical system
and a social system,
to both try and gather
data and analyze it
or to do predictions.
We want to do the same
thing computationally.
We'd like to be able
to build models in code
that we can then run to
predict effects, which we then
might test with an actual
physical experiment.
And we've seen, for example,
how you could take just
the informal problem of choosing
what to eat and turning it
into an optimization
problem-- in this case,
it was a version of something
we called a knapsack problem--
and how you could then use
that to find code to solve it.
And you've already seen two
different general methods.
You've seen greedy algorithms
that just try and do
the best thing at each stage.
And you saw dynamic programming
as an elegant solution
to finding better
ways to optimize this.
We're going to now look at
broadening the class of models
to talk about graphs.
So, obvious question
is, what's a graph?
And a graph has two
elements, two components.
It has a set of nodes,
sometimes called vertices.
Those nodes probably are
going to have some information
associated with them.
It could be as simple
as it's a name.
It could be more complicated.
A node might represent
a student record--
the grades.
And a graph might talk
about putting together
all of the grades for a class.
Associated with that,
we can't just-- well,
I should say, we
could just have nodes,
but that's kind of boring.
We want to know what
are the connections
between the elements
in my system?
And so the second thing
we're going to have
is what we call edges,
sometimes called arcs.
And an edge will
connect a pair of nodes.
We're going to see two
different ways in which we
could build graphs using edges.
The first one, the
simple one, is an edge
is going to be undirected.
And actually, I should
show this to you.
So there is the
idea of just nodes.
Those nodes, as I said,
might have information
in them, just labels or names.
They might have other
information in them.
When I want to connect
them up, the connections
could be undirected.
If you want to think of it
this way, it goes both ways.
An edge connects
two nodes together,
and that allows
sharing of information
between both of them.
In some cases, we're going
to see that we actually
want to use what we call a
directed graph, sometimes
called a digraph, in
which case the edge has
a direction from a
source to a destination,
or sometimes from a
parent to a child.
And in this case,
the information
can only flow from the
source to the child.
Now in the case
I've drawn here, it
looks like there's only
ever a single directed edge
between nodes.
I could, in fact, have
them going both directions,
from source to destination and
a separate directed edge coming
from the destination
back to the source.
And we'll see some
examples of that.
But I'm going to have edges.
Final thing is, those edges
could just be connections.
But in some cases, we're
going to put information
on the edges, for
example, weights.
The weight might
tell me how much
effort is it going to take
me to go from a source
to a destination.
And one of the
things you're going
to see as I want to
think about how do I
pass through this graph,
finding a path from one
place to another, for example,
minimizing the cost associated
with passing through the edges?
Or how do I simply find
a connection between two
nodes in this graph?
So graphs, composed
of vertices or nodes,
they're composed
of edges or arcs.
So why might we want them?
Well, we're going to see--
and you can probably
already guess--
there are lots of really useful
relationships between entities.
I might want to take
a European vacation.
After November 8,
I might really want
to take a European vacation.
So I'd like to know, what are
the possible ways by rail I
can get from Paris to London?
Well, I could pull out the
schedule and look at it.
But you could imagine, I hope,
thinking about this as a graph.
The nodes would be cities.
The links would be rail
links between them.
And then, one of the
things I might like to know
is, first of all, can I
get from Paris to London?
And then secondly,
what's the fastest
way to do it or the
cheapest way to do it?
So I'd like to explore that.
Second example, as you can see
on the list, drug discovery,
modeling of complex
molecule in terms
of the relationships between
the pieces inside of it and then
asking questions like,
what kind of energy
would it take to
convert this molecule
into a different molecule?
And how might I think about
that as a graph problem?
Third and obvious one, ancestral
relationships, family trees.
In most families,
almost all families,
they really are
trees not graphs.
Hopefully you don't
come from a family
that has strange loops in them.
But family trees are--
I know, I'm in
trouble here today.
Aren't I?
Family trees-- stay with me--
are a great demonstration of
relationships because there
its directional edges.
Right?
Parents have children.
Those children have children.
And like I say, it
comes in a natural way
of thinking about traversing
things in that tree.
And in fact, trees are a
special case of a graph.
You've already seen decision
trees in the last lecture.
But basically, a special kind
of directed graph is a tree.
And the property of
the tree is, as it
says there, any pair
of nodes are connected,
if they are connected,
by only a single path.
There are no loops.
There are no ways
to go from one node,
find a set of things that
brings you back to that node.
You can only have a single
path to those points.
And Professor Guttag
used this, for example,
to talk about solving
the knapsack problem.
A decision trees is
a really nice way
of finding that solution.
Now, I drew it this way.
In computer science, we
mostly use Australian trees.
They're upside down.
The roots are at the top.
The leaves are at the
bottom, because we
want to think about starting
at the beginning of the tree,
which is typically
something we call the root
and traversing it.
But however you
use it, trees are
going to be a useful
way of actually
thinking about representing
particular kinds of graphs.
OK.
So, when I talk in a second
about how to build graphs,
well let's spend just
a second about saying,
so why are they useful?
And if you think
about it, the world
is full of lots of networks that
are based on relationships that
could be captured by a graph.
We use them all the time.
Some of you are using
them right now--
computer networks.
You want to send an email
message from your machine
to your friend at Stanford.
That's going to get routed
through a set of links
to get there.
So the network set up by a
series of routers that pass it
along, sending something
requires an algorithm
that figures out the best way
to actually move that around.
There's a great
local company started
by an MIT professor
called Akamai
that thinks about how do
you move web content around
on the web?
Again, it's a nice
computer network problem.
I've already talked about this.
We're going to do
some other examples.
Transportation networks--
here, if you think about it,
obvious thing is make
the nodes cities.
Make the edges
roads between them.
And now questions are,
can I get to San Jose,
if you like old songs?
And what's the best
way to get to San Jose,
even if you don't
like old songs?
A network problem--
how do I analyze it?
Financial networks--
moving money around--
easily modeled by a graph.
Traditional networks--
sewer, water, electrical,
anything that distributes
content, if you like,
and the different kind of
content in this way around.
You want to model that
in terms of how you think
about flows in those networks.
How do I maximize distribution
of water in an appropriate way,
given I've got certain
capacities on different pipes,
which would mean those
edges in the graph
would have different weights?
And you get the idea--
political networks, criminal
networks, social networks.
One of the things we're
going to see with graphs
is that they can capture
interesting relationships.
So here's an example.
It's from that little web
site you can see there.
You're welcome to go look at it.
And this is a graph
analyzing The Wizard of Oz.
And what's been done
here is the size
of the node reflects the number
of scenes in which a character
shares dialog.
So you can see, obviously
Dorothy is the biggest node
there.
The edges represent
shared dialog,
so you can see who talks
to whom in this graph.
And then, this group
has done another thing,
which I'm going to mention.
We're not going to solve
today, which is you can also
do analysis on the graphs.
And in fact, the color
here has done something
called a min-flow
or max-cut problem,
which is it's tried to identify
which clusters in the graph
tend to have a lot
of interactions
within that cluster but not
very many with other clusters.
And you can kind of see.
There's some nice things here,
right, if you can read it.
This is all the
people in Kansas.
This is Glenda and the
Munchkins in that part of Oz.
There's another little cluster
over here that I can't read
and a little cluster over there.
And then the big
cluster down here.
But you can analyze the graph
to pull out pieces on it.
You can also notice, by the way,
the book is probably misnamed.
It's called The Wizard of Oz.
But notice, there's
the wizard, who
actually doesn't have
a lot of interaction
with the other
people in this story.
It's OK, literary choice.
But the graph is
representing interactions.
And I could imagine
searching that graph
to try and figure
out things about what
goes on in The Wizard of Oz.
OK.
So why are they useful?
We're going to see that not only
do graphs capture relationships
in these connected
networks, but they're
going to support inference.
They're going to be able
to reason about them.
And I want to set that up.
And then we'll actually look
at how might we build a graph.
And so here are
some ways in which
I might want to do inference.
Given a graph, I
might say, is there
a sequence of edges, of
links, between two elements?
Is there a way to
get from A to B?
What are the sequence of edges
I would use to get there?
A more interesting
question is, can I
find the least expensive
path, also known
as the shortest path?
If I want to get
from Paris to London,
I might like to do it in
the least amount of time.
What are the set of choices
I want to make to get there?
A third graph problem used a lot
is called the graph partition
problem.
Everything I've shown so
far-- actually not quite.
The first example
didn't have it.
You might think of all the
nodes having some connection
to every other node.
But that may not be true.
There may actually
be graphs where
I've got a set of connected
elements and another component
with no connections
between them.
Can I find those?
That's called the graph
partition problem.
How do I separate the graph
out into connected sets
of elements?
And then the one
that we just showed
called the min-cut
max-flow problem, is
is there an efficient
way to separate out
the highly connected elements,
the things that interact
a lot, and separate out how many
of those kinds of subgraphs,
if you like, are there
inside of my graph?
All right, let me show you
a motivation for graphs.
And then we'll build them.
I use graph theory everyday.
I'm a math nut.
It's OK, but I use
graph theory everyday.
You may as well, if you commute.
Because I use it
to figure out how
to get from my home in Lexington
down here to Cambridge.
And I use a nice
little system called
Waze It's a great way
of doing this, which
does graph theory inside of it.
So how do I get to my office?
Well, I'm going to model
the road system using
a directed graph, a digraph.
Directed graph because
streets can be one way.
And so I may only have a
single direction there.
And the idea is, I'm
going to simply let
my nodes or my
vertices be points
where I have intersections.
They're places where I can
make a choice or places where
I have terminals, things
I'm going to end up in.
The edges would just be the
connections between points,
the roads on which I can drive.
Some Boston drivers have a
different kind of digraph
in which they don't care whether
that road is drivable or not.
They just go on it.
You may have seen some of these.
But I want to keep my graphs as
real roads that I can drive on.
And I'm not going to go
against the "One Way" sign.
Each edge will have a weight.
Here I actually
have some choices.
All right, the obvious one, the
one that Waze probably uses,
is something like what's the
expected time between a source
and a destination node?
How long do I expect it to
take me to get from this point
to that?
And then, as you
can see, I'm going
to try and find overall what's
the best way to get around it.
You could pick just distance.
What's the distance
between the two?
And while there there's
a relationship here,
it's not direct because it
will depend on traffic on it.
Or you could take something
even funkier like what's
the average speed of
travel between the source
and destination node?
And once I've got
the graph, then I'm
going to solve an
optimization problem.
What's the shortest weight
between my house and my office
that gets me into work?
You can make a choice here.
As I said, a commercial system
like Waze uses this one.
My wife and I actually
have arguments
about commuting
because she's a firm
believer in the second one,
just shortest distance.
I actually like the third
one because I get anxious
when I'm driving.
And so as long as I feel like
I'm making progress, I like it.
So even though I may be
serpentining all the way
through the back roads of
Cambridge, if I'm driving fast,
I feel like I'm getting there.
So I like optimizing this
bottom one down there.
And if you see me on the road,
you'll know why I say that,
and then get out of the way.
Thinking about navigation
through systems
actually gives us a
little bit of history
because, in fact, the very first
reported use of graph theory
was exactly this problem.
Early 1700s, it's called
the Bridges of Koenigsberg.
Koenigsberg is a
city that has a set
of islands and rivers in it.
There are seven bridges that
connect up those islands.
And the question that
was posed is, is it
possible to take a walk that
traverses each of the seven
bridges exactly once?
So could you take a walk
where you go over each bridge
exactly once?
I'm showing you
this because it lets
us think about how to in fact
capture things in a model.
This problem was solved by
a great Swiss mathematician,
Leonhard Euler.
And here's what he said.
Make each island a node.
Each bridge is just
an undirected edge.
And notice in doing
that, he's abstracted
away irrelevant details.
You don't care what the
size of the island is.
You don't care how
long the bridges are.
You simply want to think about
what are the connections here?
And then you can ask a question.
In this graph, is it
possible to find a way
to walk through it so that
you go through each edge
exactly once?
And as Euler showed,
the answer is no.
And if you're curious, go
look it up on Wikipedia.
There's a nice, elegant
solution to why that's the case.
But here's what
we're going to do.
We're going to use
those graphs to think
about these kinds of problems.
And in fact, the example
I'm going to show you
are going to be
shortest path problems.
So with that, let's turn to
actually building a graph
and then thinking about
how we're going to use it.
So we're going to start
by constructing graphs.
And then what we're
going to do is
show how we can build
search algorithms
on top of those graphs.
And I hope that that flicker
is going to go away here soon.
Here we go.
So to build a graph--
actually, I shouldn't have
put this slide up so fast.
I've got lots of choices here.
If I'm thinking about maps,
one way to build a graph
would really to just be
build something with latitude
and longitude on it.
But as we've already seen, we'd
like to extract things away
from the graphs.
And so a natural
choice is to say,
let's represent the nodes in
the graph just as objects.
I'm going to use
classes for these.
So here's my
definition of a node.
It's pretty straightforward.
I'm going to assume that
the only information for now
I store in a node is just a
name, which I'm going to assume
is a string.
So I've got a class
definition for node.
It inherits from the
base Python object class.
I need ways to create
instances of nodes,
so I've got an init function.
And I'm simply going to
store inside each instance,
in other words, inside of
self, under the variable name,
whatever I passed in as
the name of that node.
Of course, if I've got ways
to create things with a name,
I need to get them back out.
So I've got a way of
selecting it back out.
If I ask an instance of
a node, what's your name?
By calling getName it
will return that value.
And to print things
out, I'm just
going to print out the name.
This is pretty straightforward.
And this, of course, lets
me now create as many nodes
as I would like.
Edges?
Well, an edge
connects up two nodes.
So again, I can do a fairly
straightforward construction
of a class.
Again, it's going to inherit
from the base Python object.
To create an
instance of an edge,
I'm going to make an assumption,
an important one which
we're going to come back to.
And the assumption is that the
arguments passed in, source
and destination, are nodes--
not names-- the
nodes themselves,
the actual instances
of the object class.
And what will I do?
Inside of the edge, I'm going
to set internal variables.
For each instance of the
edge, source and destination
are going to point
to those nodes,
to those objects that I
created out of the node class.
Next two things are
straightforward.
I can get those things back out.
And then the final
piece is, if when
I want to print out
what an edge looks like,
I'm going to ask
that it print out
the name of the source,
and then an arrow,
and then the name
of the destination.
So notice what I do there.
Given an instance of an
edge, I can print it.
And it will get the source or
the node associated with source
inside this instance, get
for that the getName method,
and then call it.
Notice the open-close paren
there to actually call it.
What does that do?
It says, inside the
edge I've got something
that points to a node.
I get that node.
I take the method
associated with it.
And I call it.
That returns the string.
And then I glue that
together with the arrow.
I do the same thing
on the destination.
And I just print it out.
Pretty straightforward,
hopefully.
OK, now I have to make a
decision about the graph.
I'm going to start with
digraphs, directed graphs.
And I need to think about how
I might represent the graph.
I can create nodes.
I can create edges, but I've
got to bring them all together.
So I'll remind you, a
digraph is a directed graph.
The edges pass in
only one direction.
And here's one
way I could do it.
Given all the sources
and all the destinations,
I could just create a big matrix
called an adjacency matrix.
The rows would be
all the sources.
The columns would be
all the destinations.
And then in a particular
spot in the matrix,
if there is an edge between
a source and a destination,
I'd just put a one.
Otherwise I'd put a zero.
Note, by the way, because
it's a directed graph,
it's not symmetric.
There might be a one between S
and D, but not between D and S,
unless there are
edges both ways.
This would be a
perfectly reasonable way
to represent a graph, but
not the most convenient one.
I'd have to go into the
matrix to look things up.
It may also not be
a very efficient way
of representing things.
For example, if there are
very few edges in the graph,
I could have a huge
matrix with mostly zeros.
And that's not the most
effective way to do it.
So I'm going to use
an alternative called
an adjacency list.
And the idea here is, for
every node in the graph.
I'm going to associate with
it a list of destinations.
That is, for a node,
what are the places
I can reach with a single edge?
OK, so let's see what that
does if we want to build it.
And yes, there's a
lot of code here,
but it's pretty easy
to look through I hope.
Here's the choice
I'm going to make.
Again, what's a graph?
It's a set of nodes.
It's a set of edges.
I'm going to have a way of
putting nodes into the graph.
And I'm going to choose to, when
I put a node into the graph,
to store it as a
key in a dictionary.
OK?
When I initialize
the graph, I'm just
going to set this
internal variable, edges,
to be an empty dictionary.
And the second
part of it is, when
I add an edge to the
graph between two
nodes from a source
to a destination,
I'm going to take that point
in the dictionary associated
with the source.
It's a key.
And associated
with it, I'm going
to just have a list of
the nodes I can reach
from edges from that source.
So notice what happens here.
If I want to add
a node, remember,
it's a node not an edge--
I'll first check to make
sure that it's not already
in the dictionary.
That little loop is
basic, or that if is
saying, if it's in this set
of keys, it will return true.
And I'm going to complain.
I'm trying to copy a
node or duplicate a node.
Otherwise, notice what I do.
When I put a node
into the dictionary,
I go into that
dictionary, edges.
I create an entry with
the key that is the node.
And the value I put in there
is initially an empty list.
I'm going to say one
more piece carefully.
It's a node not a name.
And that's OK in Python.
It is literally the
key is the node itself.
It's an object, which
is what I'd like.
All right, what if I
want to add an edge?
Well, an edge is going
to go from a source
to a destination node.
So, I'm going to get out from
the edge the source piece.
I'm going to get
out from the edge
the destination piece by
calling those methods.
Again, notice the open-close
paren, which takes the method
and actually calls it.
Because remember, an edge
was an object itself.
Given those, I'll check
to make sure that they
are both in the dictionary.
That is, I've already
added them to the graph.
I can't make a
connection between things
that aren't in the graph.
And then notice the
nice little thing I do.
Presuming I have both of
them in the dictionary,
I take the dictionary, I index
into it with the source node.
That gives me a key
into the dictionary.
I pull out the entry at
that point, which is a list,
because I created them up here.
And I add the destination node
with append into the list,
stick it back in.
So this now captures what
I said I wanted to do.
The nodes are represented
as keys in the dictionary.
And the edges are
represented by destinations
as values in the list
associated with the key.
So you can see, if I
want to see is there
an edge between a source
and a destination,
I would look at our
source in the dictionary,
and then check in
the list to see
if the destination is there.
OK, the rest of
this then follows
pretty straightforwardly.
If I want to get all the
children of a particular node,
I just go into the
dictionary, edges,
and look up the value
associated with that node.
It gives me back the list.
I've got all the
things I can reach
from that particular node.
If I want to know if a
node is in the graph,
I just search over the
keys of the dictionary.
They'll either
return true or false.
If I want to get a
node by its name, which
is going to be probably more
convenient than trying to keep
track of all the
nodes, well I could
pass in a name as a string.
And what will I do?
I'll just search over all
the keys in the dictionary,
using the getName method
associated with it--
there's the call-- then
checking to see if it's
the thing I'm looking for.
And if it is, I'll return M.
I'll return the node itself.
What about this thing here?
It might bother
you a little bit.
Wait a minute.
That raise, isn't it always
going to throw an error?
No, because I'm going to
go through this loop first.
And if I actually find
a node, that return
is going to pop me out of
the call and return the node.
So I'll only ever get
to this if in fact I
couldn't find anything here.
And so it's an appropriate
way to simply raise the error
to say, if I get to this
point, couldn't find
it, raise an error to
say the node's not there.
The last piece looks
a little funky,
Although you may have seen this.
I like to print out
information about a graph.
And I made a choice, which
is, I'm going to print out
all of the links in the graph.
So I'm going to set up a string
initially here that's empty.
And then I'm going to loop over
every key in the dictionary,
every node in the graph.
And for each one, I'm going to
look at all the destinations.
So notice, I take
the dictionary,
I look up the things
at that point.
That's a list.
I loop over that.
And I'm just going
to add in to result,
the name of the source,
an arrow, and the name
of the destination followed
by a carriage return.
I'll show you an
example in a second.
But I'm simply walking down the
graph, saying for each source,
what can it reach?
I'll print them all out.
And then I'll return everything
but the last element.
I'm going to throw away
the last carriage return
because I don't really need it.
So let me show you
an example here,
trusting that my Python has
come up the way I wanted it to.
So I'm going to load that in,
ignore that for the moment.
And I'm going to set g to--
I've got something we're going
to come back to in a second
that actually creates a graph.
And if I print out
g, it prints out,
in this case, all of the links
from source to destination,
each one on a new line.
OK.
So I can create the graphs.
That was digraphs.
Suppose I actually
want to get a graph.
Well, I'm going to make it
as a subclass of digraph.
And in particular, the
only thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to shadow the
addEdge method of digraphs.
So if you think about it,
it's so I make a graph.
If I ask it to add
edges, it's going
to use this version of addEdge.
And what am I going to do?
I know in a graph, I could
have both directions work.
So, given an edge that I
want to add into this graph,
I'll use the method
from the digraph class.
And I'll add an edge going
from source to destination.
And then I'll just create
an edge the other direction.
Destination becomes source.
Source becomes destination.
And I'll add that
into the graph.
Nice and easy,
straightforward to do.
And this is kind of nice
because, in a graph,
I don't have any directionality
associated with the edge.
I can go in either direction.
I just created
something like that.
And you might say,
well, wait a minute.
Why did I pick graph to
be a subclass of digraph?
Why not the other way around?
Reasonable question, and you
actually know the answer.
You've seen this before.
One of the things
I'd like to have
is the property that if the
client code works correctly
using an instance
of the bigger type,
it should also
work correctly when
it is using an instance of the
subtype substituted in, which
is another way of
saying anything that
works for a digraph will
also work for a graph,
but not vice versa.
And as a consequence,
it's easier
to make the graph a
subclass of digraph.
Notice the other thing
that's nice here.
One little piece of
code, just change
what it means to make an edge.
Everything else still holds.
And also notice-- you've seen
this before-- how we nicely
inherit the method
from the subclass
by explicitly calling it.
It says, from the digraph class,
get out the addEdge method
and apply it.
OK.
So we can build graphs.
We're going to do
that in a second.
Let's turn now to thinking about
I'd like to search on a graph.
And I'm going to start with
the classic graph optimization
problem.
I'd like to find
the best path home.
So, what's the shortest path
from one node to another?
And that shortest path
initially will just
be the shortest
sequence of steps.
I hope I'm not having
a little attack here.
You just saw that
screen blank out, right?
The shortest path of
steps with the property
that the source of the first
edge is the starting point.
The destination of
the last edge is
the thing I'm trying to get to.
And for any edge
in between, if I
go in my first edge from
source to say node one,
the next edge has that
destination as its source.
So there's simply a chain that
says can go from here to here
to here to here to get
all the way through.
And I'd like to find what's
the shortest number of steps?
Edges like that that will get
me from source to destination.
Ultimately, if those edges
have weights on them,
the optimization problem
I'd like to solve
is, what's the shortest
weighted path, the shortest
amount of work I have to
do to get to those places?
And if we can solve
one, we'll see
that we can solve the other
one pretty straightforwardly.
And we've already seen examples
of shortest path problems.
Clearly, finding a
route navigation is one.
Designing communication networks
is another great example
of a shortest path problem.
You'd like your message
to get to your friend
as quickly as possible
and not go as many times
around the world
before it gets there.
So what's the shortest amount
of time or the fewest links
I have to use to get there?
Lots of nice biological problems
that also captured this piece.
So here is an example.
And we're going to
use this to look
at two different
kinds of algorithms
to solve this problem.
This is a little navigation
problem from a set of cities.
Think of it as flight paths.
If you're from
Arizona, my apologies.
But once you get to Phoenix,
you can't get out of there
unless you grow from
the ashes, I guess.
[LAUGHTER]
But you know, it's a
way of dealing with how
to get around in places.
And to think about this,
here's the representation
that we'd have in the graph.
The adjacency graph
here-- or adjacency list
here is, from Boston, I
can get to Providence.
I can get to New York.
From Providence, I
can get to Boston.
I can get to New York.
From New York, I can
only get to Chicago.
Chicago, I can go to
Denver or Phoenix.
Denver, I can go to
Phoenix or New York.
And from L.A., you can
only come back to Boston.
And Phoenix has no
exits out of it.
So there is that representation.
I just want to let you see that.
Right?
There are the keys
in the dictionary.
They're all the nodes.
And there, each
one of those lists
is a set of edges from the
source to the destination.
OK.
How would I build this?
Well this is the
code I just ran.
I just want to show it to you.
I notice, by the way, in the
slides I distributed earlier,
the return g is missing there.
If you want to correct it,
I'll repost it later on.
I'm going to create a
little function that's
going to build a city graph.
I'm going to pass in a type
of graph, which I will then
call to create it.
So I could make
this as a digraph.
I could make it as a graph.
I'm going to start off
with it as a digraph.
And then notice what I do here.
I just run over a little
loop with a set of names,
creating a node with
that name and then
adding it into the graph.
All right, so node
is a class instance.
It creates-- or a
class definition--
it creates an instance.
And once I've got that, addNode
as a method on the graph.
It will simply add it in.
And then this set here, is
simply adding in the edges.
And I can do that.
I'm capturing what I had
on that previous slide.
And on a given
name to getNode, it
will get out the actual node.
And I use that coming
out of the graph g.
I do the same thing
with the getNode
from graph g for Providence.
And then I make an
edge out of that.
And then I use the method from
the graph to add the edge.
If this looks like
a lot of code,
yeah, it's a lot of words.
But it's pretty straightforward.
I'm literally creating
nodes with the names,
using the appropriate
methods, creating an edge,
adding it into the graph.
And when I'm done, I'm just
going to return the graph g.
OK.
Now I want to find
the shortest path.
I'm going to show you two
techniques for doing this.
The first one is called
depth first search.
It's similar to something
Professor Guttag showed you
when you sort of took the
left most depth first method
in terms of a search tree.
The one trick here is, because
I've got graphs not trees,
there are the
potential for loops.
So I'm simply going to keep
track of what's in the path.
And I'm never going to
go back to a node that's
already in the path.
So I don't just run in circles
going from New York to Boston
to New York to
Boston constantly.
All right.
So, the second thing
I'm going to do here
is I'm going to take
advantage of a problem you've
seen before, which is this is
literally a version of divide
and conquer.
What does that mean?
If I want to find a
path from a source node
to destination
node, if I can find
a path to some intermediate
node from source intermediate,
and then I find a path from
intermediate to destination,
the combination is obviously
a path the entire way.
So recursively, I can
just break this down
into simpler and simpler
versions of that search
problem.
So here's the idea behind
depth first search.
Start off with that source
node, that initial node.
I'm going to look
at all the edges
that leave that
node in some order,
however order it was
put into the system.
And I'm going to
follow the first edge.
I'll check to see if I'm
at the right location.
If I am, I'm done.
If I'm not, I'm going to
follow the first edge out
of that node.
So I'm actually creating
a little loop here.
And I'm going to keep doing that
until I either find the goal
node or I run out of options.
So let me show you an example.
I've got a little search
tree here, a very simple one.
Here's my source.
There is my destination.
In depth first, I'm going
to start at the source
and go down the first path.
See if I'm at the right place.
I'm not.
So I'm going to take
the first path out
of here, which
might be that one.
See if I'm in the right place.
Actually, let me
not do it that way.
Let me do it this way.
Am I in the right place?
I'm not.
So I'm going to take
the first path out
of this one, which
gets me there.
I'm still not in
the right place,
so I'm going to take the
first path out of that one.
And you can see why
it's called depth first.
I'm going as deep, if you
like, in this graph as I can,
from here, to there, to
there, to there, to there.
At this stage, I'm stuck.
There is no place
to go to, so I'm
going to go back to this node
and say, is there another edge?
In this case there isn't,
so I'll go back to here.
There's not another edge.
Go back to here.
There is another edge.
So I'm going to
go this direction.
And from here, I'll
look down there.
OK, notice I'm now going depth
first down the next chain.
There's nothing from here.
I backtrack.
There's nothing from there.
I backtrack over to here.
There's no additional
choices there,
so go all the way back to
here to follow that one.
And then we'll go down this one
again, backtrack, backtrack,
and eventually I find the
thing I'm looking for.
Depth first-- following
my way down this path.
So let's write the
code for-- yes ma'am?
AUDIENCE: Pardon me.
Is the choice of
depth first node
we go down, is that random?
PROFESSOR: The question
is, which node do I,
or which edge do I choose?
It's however I stored
it in the system.
So since it's a list, I'm
going to just make that choice.
I could have other
ways of deciding it.
But think of it as,
yeah, essentially random,
which one I would pick.
OK, let's look at the code.
Don't panic.
It's not as bad as it looks.
It actually just
captures that idea.
Ignore for the moment
this down here.
It's just going to set it up.
Depth first search, I'm going
to give it a graph, a start
node, an end node, and a path
that got me to that start
node, which initially
is just going
to be an empty list,
something that tells me what's
the shortest path
I've found so far,
which would be my best solution?
And then just a little flag
here if I want to print out
things along the way.
What do I do?
I set up path to add
in the start node.
So if path initially
is an empty list,
the first time around is
just, here's the node I'm at.
I print out some stuff and
then I say, see if I'm done.
I'm just going to stay at home.
I'm not going to go anywhere.
Unlikely to happen, but
you'll see recursively
why this is going to be nice.
If I'm not done,
then notice the loop.
I'm going to loop over all the
children of the start node.
Those are the edges I can reach.
Then those I can reach
with a single edge.
I pick the first one.
And in answer to the
question, in this case,
it would be the order in
which I started in the list.
I just pick that one up.
I then say, let's make sure
it's not already in the path
because I want to avoid loops.
And assuming it
isn't, and assuming
I don't yet have a solution,
or the best solution I have
is smaller than what
I've done so far,
oh, cool, just do
the same search.
So notice, there's
that nice recursion.
Right?
I'm going to explore.
I just picked the first
option out of that first node.
And the first thing
I do is try and see
if there's a path from that
node using the same thing.
So it's literally like
I picked this one.
I don't care about
those other edges.
I'm going to try and
take this search down.
When it comes back
with a solution,
as long as there
is a solution, I'll
say that's my best
solution so far.
And then I go back around.
Now this last little
piece here is just,
if in fact the node's
already in the path,
I'm just going to
print something
that says don't keep
doing it because you
don't need to keep going on.
And I'm going to do that loop,
taking all the paths down
until it comes back.
And only at that stage do
I go to the next portion
around this loop.
The piece down here
just sets this up,
calling it with an initial
empty list for path
and no solution for shortest.
So it's just a nice way of
putting a wrap around it that
gets things started up.
This may look a little funky.
It may look a
little bit twisted.
So let's see if it actually
does what we'd expect it to.
And to do that I'm just going
to be a little test function.
I'm going to build that
city graph I'm just
going to call "Shortest Path."
I'm going to print it out.
And I'd like to
see, is there a way
to get from Boston to Chicago?
So let's go back over to
my Python and try that out.
And I've got a call for that.
Oh, and it prints out.
I start off-- oh, so I
did it the wrong way.
It's from Chicago to Boston.
Yes, Chicago to Denver
to Phoenix, from Denver
to New York, it comes back and
says, I've already visited.
Basically concludes I can't
get from Chicago to Boston.
It's just printing
out each stage.
Let's actually look
at that a little more
carefully to see
how it got there.
So there's my example.
There is the adjacency list.
And here's what happens.
I start off in Chicago.
So that's my first node.
From Chicago, the first
edge goes to Denver.
Denver is not what
I'm looking for.
But since I am in
Denver, recursively I'm
going to call it again.
So the first edge out
of there is to Phoenix.
Again, sorry if you're
from Arizona and Phoenix.
There's nowhere to go.
So I'm going to
have to backtrack.
And that will take
me back up to Denver.
And I look at the next edge.
It takes me to New York.
From New York I'd
like to go to Chicago.
But oh, that's nice
because, remember,
that first check it says, is
Chicago already in the path?
It is.
I don't want to loop,
because otherwise I'm
simply going to go around
and around and around here.
And it may be good for
frequent flyer miles,
but it's not a great way to get
to where you're trying to go.
So I break out of it.
And now, what else
do I have left?
Chicago to Denver I've explored.
I'll look at Chicago to Phoenix.
From Phoenix there's
nowhere to go.
I go back up to Chicago.
There are no more paths.
I'm done.
OK.
Now, it turns out
you can actually
get somewhere in this graph.
So here's just another example.
I'm simply going
to show you, if I
want to go from
Boston to Phoenix,
notice the set of stages.
And you can see, notice
how at each stage
it tends to be growing.
That's that depth first.
I'm exploring the edges.
I find a path.
That's great.
But is it the shortest path?
I don't know.
So having found that path, I
try and take the next branch,
which finds a loop.
And I keep moving through
this, finding paths
until I look at all
the possible paths
and I actually return
the shortest path.
You can try running
the code on it.
But what I want you to
see is, again, this idea
that I can explore it.
But in fact, I'm going
to have to explore it
in a particular order.
But there is depth first search.
It will find a solution for me.
Alternative, it's what's
called breadth first search.
Sounds almost the same.
Again, I'm going to start
off with initial load.
I'm going to look at
all the edges that
leave that node, in some order.
I'm going to follow the
first edge as before
and see if I'm at
the right place.
If I'm not, I'm going
to follow the next edge
and do the same thing.
So whereas this went
down through the tree
as deeply as it could of
the graph, in breadth first,
I'm going to start off
taking that edge as before.
I'm not done.
I'm going to keep
track of that in case I
want to explore more of it.
But I'm going to go back over
here and follow that edge.
I'm not done.
Again, I'll keep track of that,
but I'll come back up here
and explore that one.
And oh, cool, I found a
solution in three steps.
I've reached the destination.
And notice, because
I'm exploring
all the paths of
length one before I
get to paths of length two.
Once I find a solution,
I can stop because I
know it's the shortest path.
Any other path through
here would be longer
than that particular solution.
So the loop here is
a little different.
I'm looking over all
the paths of length one.
There are all the
paths of length two.
And the one thing I'm
going to have to do
is I'm going to have to keep
track of the remaining options
here in case I have
to come down to them.
Because if I didn't find
it at the first level,
then I come down here and
look at things of length two.
OK?
So let's build that code.
Breadth first search, or
BFS, again, a graph, a start,
and an end node, something that
would just print things out
as I go along.
My initial path is
just the start point.
But now I've got to keep track
of what are the paths that I
have yet to explore?
And so for that,
I'm going to create
something called a queue.
And a queue is going
to be a list of paths.
Remember, a path
is a list of nodes.
A queue is going to
be a list of paths.
So the initial queue is
just where I've started.
And then, as long as I've got
something still to explore
and I haven't found
a solution, I'm
going to pop off the
queue the oldest element,
the thing at the beginning.
That's my temporary path.
I'll print out some
information about it.
And then I'll grab the
last element of that path.
That's the last
point in that path.
And I'll now explore.
Is it the thing I'm looking for?
In which case I'm done.
I'll return the path.
Otherwise, for each node that
you can reach from that point,
create a new path by adding
that on the end of this path
and add it into the queue
at the end of the queue.
So I'm going to
keep looping around
here until I either
find a solution here,
which I'll return.
And if I get through all of
it, I'm going to return none.
And right there, there
is that nice thing where
once I find a solution, I
know it's the shortest thing,
I can stop.
OK, let's look at
an example of this.
So I'm going to go back
over to Python, where
I've got a version of this.
I'm going to comment that out.
And down here in
breadth first search,
I've actually added a
little piece of code
that I don't have in
the handout that's
going to print out the
queue as well so we can see
what happens when we call this.
So let's take a look at it.
My initial call, there's
one thing in the queue.
It's just Boston.
I started in Boston.
So the current path
is to start in Boston.
I take that element
off the queue,
and I say what are the things
I can reach from Boston?
Oh, nice, I put two things in.
I can get from
Boston to Providence.
Boston to New York.
The top thing is
gone off the queue.
I popped it.
I've replaced it
with two things.
Or I take this, and
say, OK, from Boston
to Providence, where can
I get from Providence?
Oh, I can get to New York.
So I put that in the queue.
This has gone off.
That one is still there.
And I do that
because I haven't yet
reached the thing I'm looking
for, which was, I think,
Phoenix I was trying to get to.
And you could see
at each stage, I'm
taking the top
thing off the queue,
and asking for all the
things that I can get to,
and adding them to it.
And notice, in some cases,
it may be more than one.
For example, which
one do I want here?
Right here, if I take
Boston, New York to Chicago,
from Chicago I
can get to Denver.
So there's one new path.
I can also get to Phoenix.
There's a second new path.
Also notice how they
are only growing slowly
as I build them out.
And in fact, if we go back,
we can see that nicely
by looking at what happens if
we were to actually trace this
along.
So Boston to Phoenix,
I start at Boston.
Then I look at
that and then that.
Those are all the
paths of length one.
Having exhausted
those, oh nice, I'm
looking at paths of length two,
and then paths of length three,
and then paths the
length four, until I
found the one that I wanted.
And here's one other
way of looking at it.
Breadth first says, I'll look
at each path of length one.
And then, oh yes,
I avoid the loop.
I look at each
path of length two,
then paths of length
three, until I actually
find the solution.
Subtle difference,
different performance.
Depth first, I'm
always following
the next available edge until
I get stuck and I backtrack.
Breadth first, I'm always
exploring the next equal length
option.
And I just have to keep
track in that queue
of the things I have left to
do as I walk my way through.
What about weighted
shortest path?
Well, as the
mathematicians say, we
leave this is an easy
exercise for the reader.
It's a little unfair.
The idea would be, imagine on
my edges, it's not just a step,
but I have a weight.
Flying to L.A. Is a
little longer than flying
from Boston to New York.
What I'd like to do is do the
same kind of optimization,
but now just minimizing the sum
of the weights on the edges,
not the number of edges.
As you might guess,
depth first search
is easily modified to do this.
The cost now would
simply be what's
the sum of those weights?
And again, I would have to
search all possible options
till I find a solution.
Unfortunately,
breadth first search
can't easily be modified because
the short weighted path may
have many more than the
minimum number of loops.
And I'd have to think
about how to adjust
it to make that happen.
But to pull it together,
here's a new model--
graphs.
Great way of
representing networks,
collections of entities with
relationships between them.
There are lots of nice
graph optimization problems.
And we've just shown you
two examples of that.
But we'll come back to more
examples as we go along.
And with that, we'll
see you next time.